hello everyone and welcome to the active
inference Liv stream this is active
inference Liv stream 13.1 and it is
January 5th
2021 happy New Year everyone welcome to
the active inference lab the active
inference lab is an experiment in online
team communication learning and practice
related to active
inference feed back you can find us at
our website Twitter email YouTube or
keybase teams this is a recorded and an
archived live stream so please provide
us with feedback so we can improve our
work all backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome here and keep in mind video
etiquette for live streams for 2021 we
are going to be meeting every Tuesday
regularly at 7: to 9:00 a.m. pafic time
and then we'll plan other special
sessions as things come up and for
different time zones you can go to this
link and see a spreadsheet and here we
are in the first week with the first
paper and next week we'll be discussing
the same one so hello everyone thanks
for coming on live and thanks everybody
who's watching let's introduce ourselves
please give a short introduction or
check-in especially if it's your first
time on the stream and then pass it to
somebody who hasn't spoken so I'm Daniel
I'm in Davis and I'll pass it to Colin
I'm Colin D young and I'm in Minneapolis
Minnesota um I'm a professor in the
psychology department here at the
University of
Minnesota and excited to be here um I'll
pass it on to
Stephen oh hello I'm Stephen I'm based
in Toronto um I'm doing my practice
based PhD at Canary Christ Church
University and uh pleased to be here as
well pass it to
Shannon hey I'm Shannon PRS I'm in South
Dakota so also in the snow but I'm based
at the University of California in
Merced during my PhD also I'll pass it
to
Marco hi I'm Marco um I'm from Holland
and used to work on active entrance in
London but now I'm just um enjoying the
progress from the sidelines
I'll pass it to uh
Ean thank you my name isan I'm from
Russia from Moscow and I interested in
free energy principal and as it related
with systems engineering and I pass it
to uh excuse me what is your name my
friend
Dave let's go to Dave hi Dave Douglas
I'm retired from Information Technology
I live in the Philippines and I did
about equal amounts of graduate level
work in computer science Linguistics and
psychology but have only a lowly
ba cool let's go to blue and then Adam
hi good morning everyone my name is blue
Knight and I am an independent research
consultant based out of New
Mexico and Adam
welcome hi I'm Adam sorry I'm late I
am based out of Bloomington
Indiana uh I'm a postural
researcher cool well welcome everyone
thanks so much for coming on filling out
the Hollywood Square that we have here
for these warm-up questions it'll be
great to hear from everyone just raise
your hand if you have a thought I'll
just put up the first two totally just
raise your hand as you want to add
something first would be what is
something about human personality or
emotions that you would want to see
captured in a good model or
understanding or
education and then also what is
something that you liked or remembered
about the paper and um I think there was
a few memorable parts of the paper just
while people are raising their hand uh I
think just the idea of going from a
statistical understanding of the big
five as principal component Dimensions
to being the outputs of a cybernetic
system is really an interesting topic
so maybe if uh anyone wants to raise
their hand on this one or
Adam or Colin maybe how do you go about
introducing uh the the need for your
kind of paper to an audience like where
do you start out with the interesting
part about personality that you want to
capture in your
model well uh shall I jump in then um
and when you say raise hand do you mean
this little button here or you like
actually just wave at the screen
probably with the button all right well
works that works um so uh one of the
things that I noticed in your summary of
the paper uh was something that I often
encounter from people working in other
scientific Fields uh which is a certain
degree of skepticism about the big five
because of their origin in uh natural
language and um and because you know
when you see a diagram that's like a
hierarchy of personality traits I you
know in the figure there I was careful
to note that that is not supposed to be
a diagram of causal structure in the
individual because there's this
interesting problem where we use the
same visual language for causal models
of you know boxes and circles and arrows
uh and for statistical models in which
we're looking at the relationships among
variables but obviously those are not
directly
translatable and um so the way that I
would pose the basic question that's of
Interest here is uh why do certain
traits of people tend to Cluster
together I think that that's really the
core of what I'm interested in and what
we're interested in if we're talking
about the sources of Personality a lot
of Personality research in the last 40
years or so since the big F emerged as
kind of an organizing consensus
framework has really been focused on
questions of prediction like if we have
these assessments of people's
personality Tendencies what kind of
outcomes does it predict for them
um also potentially like what are
trajectories of uh change and
development of these things over time
but I'm interested in a question that is
a lot less studied which is where do
these patterns come from in the first
place um and so I think the way that to
think about the kind of statistical
element here is simply that there is an
observation that if we have a large set
of descriptions of uh people's
personality and it doesn't have to be
from the natural language that was just
one good source for a relatively
unbiased set of descriptions of people
was to go into the dictionary and just
pull out the adjectives that could
describe people um but we see very
similar pattern of factors like the big
five if we start with a lot of say
existing personality questionnaires that
weren't designed to measure the big five
you throw them all together you still
get the big five um so as long as we
have a sufficiently large set of
descriptions of personality and we have
ratings on them uh they tend to Cluster
together in reliable ways and um as long
as they are valid you know as long as
when we say that somebody's talkative
that really does mean that they talk
more than other people do and there's a
lot of evidence for the basic levels of
validity of Personality
ratings then the question is why is it
that people who are talkative also tend
to be uh more sociable also tend to
experience more positive emotions also
tend to be more physically active also
tend to be uh let's say more interested
in excitement and uh
dangerous you know risky Pursuits so
we've got a whole bunch of things that
cluster together and the question is why
and so you know that was a list of
low-level traits that are grouped
together within extra version and that's
just a statistical observation those
people who tend to have more of one of
those things also tend to have more of
another and so I see fundamentally the
question that I'm interested in is what
are the underlying mechanisms uh that
vary from person to person um that drive
these patterns of co-occurrence of
particular
characteristics thank you for that
Shannon thanks for that um really nice
sort of overview introduction um I was
sort of wondering going through this
paper you talk about what are the
differences that are um can be ascribed
to individuals and their individual
personalities that lead to you know
traits like extraversion or what have
you um but what if there is nothing
unique to any individual that gives rise
to a personality trait and I wonder
where does um culture and social
interaction fit into this kind of model
and that's just a question that I'm
interested in throughout the next couple
of hours that we're here
today nice good question anyone I put up
also the third one
blue so something as I was wondering
about like as I was reading the paper
was you know the Big Five personality
and like it's um you know grounded in
genetic uh influences right um but like
attachment Theory and like there's like
a bunch of work that's been done in mice
like showing like you know the nurturing
of parents and you know whether you're
attachment avoidant or attachment
anxious or um you know attachment secure
that's also something I think would be
fun and interesting to um model in in
the free energy kind of way like put
into into this framework and I think it
has like some cool um you know impacts
for like team building and and how um
you know like whether I don't know I
just think it would be it would be
interesting and maybe um impactful in in
this kind of framework cool and blew to
that point I just saw a paper this uh
morning from Anna Cuna at all an axle
constant the first prior from co-
embodiment to co- homeostasis in early
life about this transition from like a
truly in utero embedded being to
different types of physiological
dependencies social and cultural so it
is interesting to think about all right
we have an individual orientation around
the big five it's about the individual
in relationship to different types of
settings but then how do you capture
that element of Niche construction or of
group dynamics or of these other aspects
that are relational I'm I'm just curious
Colin or or Adam like where does the uh
other how how does that enter into it
this idea of the cultural influences in
on personality because someone's
personality might be manifested in a
really specific setting because of their
local
context I could just say something about
that that is relevant I think to both of
the two questions that have just been
asked uh which is just to keep in mind
that U these personality traits are
descriptions of uh you know persistent
patterns of people people's behavior and
we know that they are genetically
influenced but we also know that they're
not entirely determined by genetics they
are also determined by environmental
influences and so the way that I think
about this is that you have these uh you
know these mechanisms that are allowing
people to function and some parameters
of those mechanisms must be reasonably
persistent to produce these persistent
patterns of behavior but the the things
that set those parameters and that tweak
them if there's change in personality
over time can be both
genetically programmed and
environmentally programmed right so
there are things there are events that
happen to people for example their
relations to their primary caregiver and
attachment um that shape what these
settings are going to be persistently in
life um and so I think there's
definitely room for thinking about
environmental inputs uh to these systems
and shaping of these parameters uh as
well as genetic
ones cool
and Colin this point you raised earlier
about uh graphical models and just
drawing a connection among different
variables is that a causal model is that
a statistical model are those different
what if you're talking about causal
entropy or you're doing a causal uh you
know model like a structural equation
modeling or even if it's a linear
aggression it's going to be interpreted
as a causal influence and they'll put in
the discussion oh it could be a
different way it could just be
correlation but it's really hard to
disentangle that um yeah
Marco hi thanks um so first of all um I
haven't fully read the paper I kind of
recently got out of a pandemic um
Slumber um but but it sounds very
interesting from what I've read and
heard so far and as far the first
question about what I'd like to see it
might be a bit um in the far future but
I think ideally um this would all
connect sooner or later to the work on
neurop phenomenology the kind of Ideal
Vision I have is for example now we
talking about um genetic prior and
environmental inputs but I think the
beautiful part about cybernetics is the
kind of reflex of action and so
Consciousness or phenomenology is
basically a mediator or moderator of the
way that environmental inputs kind of
influence or continuing progression of
Personality or um traits and and
characteristics and so ideally um I
would love to see a well I would love to
hear if it's possible to make a
synthesis of for example the work from
psychoanalysis Psychotherapy everything
that kind of uh explores and navigates
these particular mechanisms from a
first- person kind of view how to
navigate the experience of being engaged
in the world and I'm just wondering
about Adams or col someone else's
thoughts on how to possibly connect that
phenomological um description of
mechanisms and processes with the more
formal um basic models that we're now
exploring in this kind of work
if that makes sense yeah very nice Adam
and then anyone
else uh hello can you hear me yep great
um so I guess to uh try to address a
couple things
um so yeah uh Marco just thrust us into
like the deepest possible territory like
right away um and so I guess I'll
briefly comment on that uh Second but
the I guess the first thing in terms of
um social context and uh Niche
construction and the more inter
subjective aspects and context um
sensitivity of
Personality
uh active inferential modeling is really
well equipped to uh address all of that
uh in this paper it was more uh the
focus was just kind of exploring what K
and I both perceive to be a very rich
set of correspondences between between
the free energy principle and active
inference and uh his theory of
cybernetic Big Five Theory but in um
modeling work you can uh bring in all of
those details and explore them in their
particulars so I'm currently
collaborating on a project where we're
trying to model things like extroversion
within these um social Choice tasks and
so how you show up it's going to be a
function of you know both the task
environment and you
and this interaction that's going to
evoke a given style pattern but you'll
have these um parameters uh these hyper
priors are um over the different um
aspects of the generative model which
through iterated policy selection and uh
updating will basically concentrate
their probability mass in different ways
and result in different
parameterizations and then different
emergent behavior and what you can see
happen is you can get uh these basically
attractors form as this process proceeds
over time these behavioral attractors
where you the concentration of your
prior for engaging in the world in a
certain way causes you to enact a given
pattern which causes you to uh even more
update in that direction like your your
D Matrix like where am I in this
environment uh you know what do you
expect to be perceiving your a matrices
all the different like components that
You' use to try to
model the parts of an agent these were
all your prior over these all get
updated will then cause the pattern of
in action so on and so forth and that
over time this could cause you to be in
this attractor where you have this
enduring stability um how enduring you
know it would depend
on a variety of things uh and but so I
guess that's one so in this process uh
the social context who you're
interacting with that would make make
all the difference in terms of like how
the kind of ball rolls down this
epigenetic landscape like how you end up
like carving out a given pattern for
this agent uh with respect to uh
neurophenomenology and just the uh
actually getting
it the richness of
experience there's a sense in which all
active influential modeling is already
in a way um kind of personality modeling
it's like you're kind of getting into
like um uh these enduring um you these
cybernet what they're thinking them as
these like cybernetic um parameters for
this fundamental process um or just the
your ability to describe um the essence
of the system uh the it's its normal
form description this this maximally
encompassing uh description of the modes
of where you expect Define the system as
a kind of probabilistic density in some
kind of multi-dimensional phase space um
if you have such a a attracting Network
structure that you can describe in a way
you could call that the personality of
the system um but cybern big five Theory
um kind of goes further and and or it
it's grounding this in terms of well why
should we expect certain modes over
others why should we expect this then
relates it back to the fundamental
cybernetic cycle of of goal Pursuit that
any agent has to do um so with respect
to neurop phenomenology and it seems
like the attempts to get at this within
active inference things like uh
sophisticated effect of inference the
the models of uh metacognition where
they're beginning to Model A kinds of
mindful processing of reflecting on your
um your confidence and and then this
influencing your uh
you you have having an actual model of
your epistemic status you reflect you
reflecting on this and this influencing
how you sample influencing uh how
confident you are in different ways um
influencing What policies you end up
deploying uh these things to the extent
that they allow for um phenomenological
richness they could be brought into an
agent model and you're beginning to do a
connection between neurop phenomenology
or a process theory of that would dock
of phenomenology and personality
modeling so those are some thoughts nice
thanks and to add on that Adam because
that was really well said it's almost
like some of these past papers we've
been discussing were the neutral
infrastructure or the architecture or
the tools to have agents that can have
memory or can have affect or can
perceive veillance or get worried so we
talked that in a very neutral framework
like it's a parameter in the model
however in the real world as Colin was
getting at there's these extremely deep
correlations with different outcomes of
systems people who like to text more
also like to video chat more or
something and that might not be
surprising but it these Trends are very
distinct and so we are getting at this
generative model idea personality as a
generator of outcomes in different
niches so Inseparable from the niche
and um it's just an interesting way to
see how the cybernetic big five has come
from a more psychological area so it has
uh that sort of um toe of the neurop
phenomenology and the real correlations
in the world and then there's the
neutral framework that sort of maps onto
that we have Steph and then
Colin yeah I like what's been said about
neurophenomenology and I'd also say that
one of the things that's good about the
this this work with traits is it it's
starting to bring work that's coming
from um what you could say realist
settings codifying it and then finding
the patterns and it's given us more U
material coming the other way we've had
some work around a lot of work with
affordances and niches and then
obviously you've got the models which
start to create Dynamics and show and
then you start to see where these two
things meet but I would also say micro
I've been looking at lot of micr
phenomenology and the actual structuring
of experience and attention and I think
that um what can be interesting is these
traits if these traits can also get
brought down into micr phenomenology and
ways of like how is the
structure of the environment body
mind um happening and and where are
their times because what I think with a
lot of the trait works is it does have a
normative assumption about the type of
Life someone's in around which you then
standardize and then get these patterns
but you do find if you take people into
some other types of space or other types
of attentional State be it a more
grounded State maybe a a performative
state maybe a a space Which is less
Western so to speak less goal
orientated um that might shift so this
might be like this is where that is when
people are at this normative mediated
sort of normative like calculated way of
getting everyone at like the gold
directed Norm for a
Westerner um and then can these
different components to that be sort of
treated and also looked at how do they
vary as we move like not just as the
five but IND you know as as individual
kind of um tap ways to tap into
affordances when do these change more or
less when we bring people into another
type of way of a regime of attention or
another set of affordances which is
outside the normal for our
cultural go driven way of being in the
west okay
Colin and then Marco I just had a couple
of thoughts about phenomenology since
that's been a a theme um recently um
first of all I think one interesting
thing to think about in relation to uh
trait approaches is that when we do
assessments of Personality using
self-report questionnaires you know
which is not the only way that you can
do it of course you can have other
people you know rate the personality of
somebody and we tend to see very similar
results if we use other people's ratings
versus self- ratings um although there's
also evidence that there's some
incremental validity there in other
words you know things about yourself
that other people don't know so that
there's some unique validity to your
reports but other people also know
things about you that you don't know so
there's also some unique validity to
other people's reports on your
personality but as long as we're talking
about the self-reports then that is at
base a kind of you know crude
phenomenological measure right because
you're saying what are you like what is
your experience of your s like are you
the kind of person who's anxious are you
the kind of person who likes art you
know and we get a long list of people's
responses on these things and then we uh
infer their General patterns of uh
behavior from them
and so I do think you know one of the
things that I've always been interested
in is that personality is not just
patterns of behavior from a third person
perspective it's also patterns of
experience from a firstperson
perspective and so when we look at the
contents of Personality questionnaires
you know they involve descriptions of
emotion and types of cognition and
patterns of motivation that can all be
experienced you know phenomenologically
in the first person as well and so we're
using this kind of first representation
and understanding of ourselves to then
try to infer these General patterns of
behavior that have validity from an
objective third person perspective as
well and then just in terms of like
drilling down to this kind of micr
phenomenology idea we do know things
about particular patterns of processing
that are associated with different
personality traits uh so for example we
just published a paper showing that
extraversion is associated with the
tendency to be influenced by uh reward
in an implicit learning context right so
you're doing a task where you're making
this like discrimination between two
very similar options um and you're
rewarded more for getting correct
responses to one option relative to the
other well what you see is that um
people's behavior becomes biased toward
that option but the degree it becomes
biased is actually correlated with
extroversion and that's part of how we
you know have support for the theory
that fundamentally what causes all of
these different extroverted behaviors to
cohere is sensitivity to reward um and
so you can think of that from the third
person as like here's a process of you
know reward um mapping but you can also
think well what is it like from for this
individual this is the kind of person
who's going to be more uh perceptive of
possibilities for uh rewarding inter
interactions for incentives in their
environment so I think you can always
sort of flip back and forth between
taking the phenomenological and the more
U third person perspective on these
things cool thanks
Marco yeah uh thanks actually um kind of
ties into that because I was kind of
wondering if you could share some
thoughts on the relation between value
systems such as pratic value or affect
and epistemic sence and curiosity with
this uh model of Personality for example
I did read that you said the fundamental
components are um the goal the
interpretation and the strategy right um
and and I would say that that value I
mean I would guess that value is more
about the interpretation right so that
you have some kind of scaler or some
other dimension by which you can compare
certain current real States and expected
States um and tying into that uh I guess
it's a separate question but I think I
guess I'm going back to the personality
and phenomenology because maybe you
could share some thoughts and to what
extent personality can be seen as an as
a natural consequence of the Cy IC
imperative where conscience has
basically instrumentalized to be the
regulator of uh entire mind body system
as it were um because I guess I have
some image picture of uh reses of
reflexive attention right so there must
be some cyb active system or set of
systems ecosystem if you will um that's
regulating or controlling the entire
mind body system or large portions of it
um but that in itself then has has to
necessarily buy free energy or back of
inference have to have some kind of um
uh imperative to decide or policies to
pick on how to engage with that bigger
mindbody ecosystem if that makes sense
beautiful thank you Adam and then anyone
else darn it Marco uh that was awesome
yeah was that was epic it was epic Adam
and then Sasha and then we'll leave the
warm-up
so I guess
uh two things Com or a few things coming
to mind
um
so I really like this idea of thinking
of um your Consciousness as a as a kind
of modeling for the sake of cybernetic
control and uh with hopefully you know
some degree of not perfect but some
degree of fidelity for modeling that
which is modeled uh good regulator
theorem to regulate a system you have to
have a decent enough model um
the and so there's a sense in which um
towards this end uh being able to uh
have your modeling process reflect on
itself and model itself uh that that
could be a very useful thing uh if you
get it right
um and a very bad thing if you get it
wrong um the and so related to things
like and it could even be that you know
these parameter Ts for
these they might stripe it across like
multiple levels of abstraction something
like curiosity so you could have like a
kind of um uh curiosity that has a
phenomenology in terms of like the way
like a physicist would describe it as
like a phenomenological description of
behavior that's just like showing the
emerg behavior and this looks like a
more Curious system in the way it's like
sussing out State space then you might
also get to like uh curiosity in terms
of the uh what it feels like to be
curious and what those those motivations
those free energy gradients they going
to try to annihilate those different
sources of Desire of pull um what that's
like
experientially um and so yeah it seems
like something like curiosity would be
reflected at multiple levels of
organization uh maybe even with some uh
weird shifts in terms of like the way it
shows up across uh levels of
analysis um the GU a
few other ideas are coming to mind would
be um there seems to be a sense in which
if so we're talking about you someone
reporting on their experience um you can
think of these reports both in terms of
the uh perceptual inferences that are uh
going into them and then the report is a
kind of action as a kind of Act of
inference and uh each of these aspects
you know for in like you could set up a
generative model for each of these and
you would have for instance a given kind
of uh you know Matrix to describe the
perception like given a given set of
observations what's the state that you
then infer and so this could be like
some aspects of like so what isn't
agent what is a person uh noticing in
different circumstances and so this is
like what is what is it in particular
that is entering into their experience
where does their attention go you could
also though have like their attention
not just in terms of a sort of like uh a
salience but a kind of like active
curiosity and a a sampling from the
environment as a kind of mental act and
so this then will influence like what's
getting fed into the stream of
experience and what it's like to be uh a
particular kind of agent particular kind
of particular kind of person in a
particular kind of
situation
um those are some thoughts cool we'll
return to that idea about being in the
niche for a particular kind of agent
we'll do Sasha and then Colin with the
last word on the
intro awesome yeah thank you um really
great conversation I've already reduced
my uncertainty on a lot of the questions
I came in with um uh than thank you
Colin for explaining that um behavior is
not the same thing as personality
because that's something I was starting
to wonder um so it's yeah relevant that
personality uh contains as part of it
the self-report of the um individual's
experience um and then uh I like what
you said about your most recent work
that sounds really interesting and kind
of Falls in line with um active
inference uh as reducing uncertainty
about our environment and so it seems
that uh extroverts and introverts have a
different sensitivity to
um uh sens sensitivity to Precision
about their world where extroverts are
more sensitive to reward and um updating
their generative model from the external
inputs like mainly I'm thinking social
but of course could be other things um
so that's an interesting how it fits
into into this model of of active
inference as well and um I guess my last
thought is is there another level up um
here where we can talk about people who
are also sensitive to
Precision about personality tests and um
others Quantified Self
um whether there's a metric for that
kind of like self-reflection part of it
um and if that I think some sometimes
that can seem a bit
like a a self-fulfilling prophecy or
like I know I'm the kind of person who
does this so I expect this personality
test to tell me this um where you're
actually not sensitive to new
information you just want uh kind of
confirmation on what you already think
so but yeah okay interesting stuff Colin
and then we're going to move to the next
section okay so quickly then just a
couple of thoughts on the last couple of
comments
um so first of all you raised something
Sasha that is important which is that
personality tests are certainly fallible
right they're not a great form of
measurement they're just the best form
of measurement we have for assessing
people's personalities and the reason
for that is that it's really hard to get
at an assessment of people's persistent
patterns in all of their you know
different aspects of functioning uh with
anything other than relying on people to
tell you about it right you could try to
come up with you know like some complex
set of tasks and people come into the
lab and do all these things and you
videotape them and somehow that's going
to you're going to extract all the
information about their personality from
that by a carefully chosen set of things
that you have them go through you know
it' be a huge amount of work and you'd
be learning less about what they're like
in general than just asking them a bunch
of questions so you know this is always
a perennial problem it's like well there
are these difficulties with self-reports
people have biases they uh you know they
are motivated to think of themselves as
being more desirable in various ways
than they are from a you know social
desirability perspective uh and so what
what can you do about that and yeah
there are certainly studies of you know
the degree to which people are accurate
in their personality assessment and like
the degree to which if they assess their
own personality how much does that agree
with other people's assessments of their
personality and larger discrepancies can
be predictive of things sometimes of
psychological problems um so there's a
you know there's a whole area of
studying that um but I think I like this
idea of people who have curiosity about
their own personalities um and that kind
of leads into something I just wanted to
say generally about personality which is
that definitely uh extroversion is
related to this kind of curiosity about
things that are potentially rewarding
but if we think about curiosity more
generally as a sensitivity to the reward
value of information per se so just
essentially the motivation to improve
the quality of our interpretations of
the world in terms of that uh language
of interpretations and goals and
strategies then we have a there's a
pretty clear sense that Curiosity of
that sort of general form is the core of
one of the big five traits so the
openness to experience and intellect
dimension of the big five is really
focused on people's curiosity uh and
hunger for information essentially
whether that be more about aesthetic and
perceptual information related to
openness to experience or whether it's
related to abstract information related
to to intellectual issues um so that
that seems to be one of the really core
dimensions of people's personalities so
I do think there's a there's a very
clear way to connect that into this idea
of you know foraging for uh for
information and seeking out increased
entropy for the sake of reducing entropy
uh over time you know which is what
learning is essentially so there there
are good connections there
definitely interesting and Adam just one
quick last
note uh so yeah quickly
um guess before we temporarily close off
the phenomenology thread um it's seems
like there's a really uh Rich kind of
biral relationship between uh
personality science an active inference
and that uh with personality science you
actually have this
like like they're all basically these um
uh from the personality modelers I met
they're all these very like integrative
generalists approaching this hairball of
a problem from as many ways as they can
and basically bootstrapping their
themselves to validity and reliability
and so they've come up with uh a really
rich literature of phenomena to populate
the
phenomenology and AC of inference
provides the sort of like places where
you want to kind of dig in deeper onto
like well what is the exact like causal
mechanism so like cybernetic Big Five
theory was probably like best um
impersonality science of getting at
causal processes of like how you're
uh what where are these traits coming
from and what are they actually doing
for the agent so now you can bring an
act of inference and describe agents of
cybernetic systems run simulations uh
generate things that would correspond to
different aspects of Personality like
for instance the dopamine system and
curiosity you now can modify your
parameter over policy selection and see
what then unfolds with respect to both
over Acts or mental acts like
attentional shifts um just one final
thing before we go to the next part is
uh there's some uh in the paper we start
to talk about this idea of like a p
struct um or like this kind of object
that could be used in something like
comput computational Psychiatry for um
kind of pooling data over multiple
multiple people to like come up with um
basically a general personality model
that you can deploy for different agents
um we might want to go into the Weeds on
that later um to the extent we can but
the thing I want to get at is that uh
the one thing to model an AC of
inference is we are all personality
modelers it's like we are all
necessarily like super forecasters
trying to predict the future we are all
also personality modelers trying to
predict each other and ourselves and
part of this would be towards this end
well what kind of agent do I think I am
what do I think my personality is like
what do I think is going to be either
more situation like what's going to be
enduring uh what's going to be you can
have personality be enduring but
variable so what's going to be uh how
variable are these aspects of Me How
likely are they to endure these are the
questions you have to ask of yourself
and other agents in order to govern the
interactions in the best of your ability
well said Adam it really just highlights
how much people even though we say
things like well we don't know even
given someone's personality we don't
know what they're going to do it's like
yeah but you know what language they're
going to speak and so in the broad
scheme of things you've actually reduced
your uncertainty quite a lot and if
you're not 99.9% aligned with that agent
who's like you in the niche sharing an
interface with you that conflict or
adversarial relationship or just risk
surface is going to spiral and so it's
all about this interface yeah Marco if
you want to go
ahead yeah thanks U sorry I I didn't get
get that far in the paper but that sound
really interesting I just briefly
skimmed the section on it so so it
sounds like the P structure is basically
allowing for a heris contextual
dependency so they have the generic
generative models of your being and the
and the P structure kind of uh links the
current context to the generic uh kind
of models and that allows for the
variation over different situations I
mean I'm emphasizing theistic nature of
it because personality basically can be
seen as a very useful theistic for how
to act in the world does that make sense
or should I just read more in the paper
no I think that's really a great uh
connection there and a setup I think in
figure two or when we see the graphical
model maybe let's think about where this
structure would play in and then
emphasize its role as a statistical
construct that reduces our uncertainty
about regularities in the world just
like every other kind of statistical
modeling framework does um and then I
think we'll be able to come back to that
P stru question but what a fun uh
warm-up
section good times so in today we did
the introductions and warm-up and then
we'll have the sections of this paper
which maybe if you're listening you've
read or not and that is the integrating
cybernetic Big Five Theory with free
energy principle a new strategy for
modeling personalities as complex
systems by saffron and D young both of
whom are on this call so in this set of
slides we do have a bunch of uh the
abstract road map some other stuff but I
think there are so many interesting
threads we've raised let's just try to
walk through all of them um in no
specific order but really think about
what topics do we want to highlight for
next week when we talk about the same
paper and how will we get deeper into
some of these threads that we've raised
today in the discussion so here's the
ases and claims slide and Adam or Colin
um what was just your intention with the
paper and after doing it where do you
see the next implications of the paper
or the next research directions for what
you kind of want to do in that direction
and if that verges into some of the
figures just me mention it and I'll go
to that
figure um well I think the our basic
motivation for doing it was just that we
had already been talking together about
topics of mutual interest and and the
opportunity to write this chapter came
up and I thought oh this would be a
really fun thing to uh a good excuse to
do something with Adam and kind of get
our thoughts together and you know
actually
written down and out there in the world
um and so you know I think he and I
probably have slightly different
incentives for where this is going next
um he's more interested in the process
processes of modeling um whereas I'm
more interested in you know generating
knowledge about the specific mechanisms
and uh you know brain processes that
underly different personality traits and
risks for different types of
psychopathology that are tied to
different personality traits um but um
yeah I think I mean to me this is just a
really nice way to kind of connect U my
thinking about personality with this uh
what seems to me to be a really
generative perspective with the whole Fe
framework and what's happening with that
in science in
general I'm sure Adam has some other
thoughts about that
too yeah go for it Adam but that was
very interesting Colin thanks
oh I mean for me that was primarily the
thing like col and I were already kind
of going into the weeds together and
having fun with it and so it's then uh
basically uh uh iarpa brought together
this meeting of personality modelers to
create this book um modeling persons and
situations um basically seeing the
extent to which personality science
could do uh predictive modeling of
Agents um basically they want to recapit
the plot of westw world as far as I can
tell um so I'm actually not joking but
except I am uh but yeah so my primarily
uh uh interest would be just uh what the
heck our persons uh and uh what can they
be and how can we understand them and uh
who am I and what do I
want yeah and also one thing we haven't
raised is who or what is a person
there's personality as being the
statistic iCal regularities of agent in
Niche so that's just uh like a person in
an exoskeleton you could have some sort
of model for that or a person with other
types of constraints on or something
like that but then there's the idea of
like what is a person legally what is a
person culturally and all these ideas
are coming into play with modeling legal
persons and physical persons and regul
statistical regularities that include
our digital affordances all of that is
becoming integrated our digital Persona
is that included in these uh emotive
models there's just a lot of really
interesting stuff to think about there
so then just copied on the screen for
people who are looking is the abstract
you can pause the video there and here
is the road map then we'll have the
figures and then there's just one kind
of interesting general question from an
audience but in the road map just if you
have any thoughts on the layout or the
authors could give a point if they
wanted to about why they arranged it the
way they arranged it or which parts they
thought were important if somebody was
just going to read one section or any
thoughts on that otherwise we can just
go to the figures but okay let me know
if you want to return to this otherwise
it's just the headers of the paper all
right so here's figure one and Colin
this really returns to your point from
earlier about the graphical models what
do Connections in graphical models
represent and that's very related to a
general question of like what do
variables repres represent principal
component one what does that represent
what English word are we going to put on
that you know MX plus b linear model
what are we going to call x what is the
slope what is that going to be called
and then how does that play out
graphically whether in an equation or
whether in a drawing like this so I
would love to hear your thoughts and
then anyone else can raise their hand on
this one okay so I made the basic
distinction earlier between a uh a St a
statistical model of covariance like a
structural equation model uh I think
it's really important not to call
structural equation models causal models
because they're not that drives me crazy
when people refer to causal modeling and
all they're doing is a set of regression
paths right what that is fundamentally
is trying to U you know recreate
patterns of covariance in data and if
you have special kinds of data like with
temporal priority or where some variable
has actually been manipulated uh then
you can actually interpret um you know
causal effects from covariant structure
but uh just in and of itself there's
nothing inherently causal about
structural equation modeling or
regression um this model here however is
different this is actually intended as a
conceptual causal model so these are not
just looking at correlations between
different variables in a population this
is thinking about the actual causal
processes that produce the functions of
a of an individual agent specifically a
human being um and so what this is this
is just sort of like a way to
encapsulate an overview of the way that
my theory uh defines personality traits
and characteristic adaptations which are
the two elements of exhaustive elements
of Personality uh in the theory and so
the idea is that you know we know from
Decades of research that both genetics
and the environment contribute to uh
people's personality traits and the uh
idea is
that personality traits are patterns of
behavor that's why they have their own
separate box there there's sometimes a
tendency in personality psychology to
say well what the trait really is is
some underlying thing that causes
people's behavior um but I think that
that leads to confusion because what we
actually measure when we measure
personality traits is a description of
regularities in the person's behavior
and experience uh so I think it's
important to keep that clear but then
the the middle box there the relatively
stable parameters of cybernetic
mechanisms is trying to say something
about where those patterns of regularity
come from and so the personality traits
are not some underlying causal process
that generates personality they are just
the patterns now they themselves do have
Downstream causal effects however
because let's say I'm the kind of person
who talks all the time well that's going
to have consequences on the world around
me right and that will maybe lead me to
develop different patterns of adaptation
to my environment to have different
outcomes on the people around me it's
going to lead to different outcomes and
different adaptations so that's the
final box there um and then there just
you know there's identification of
feedback loops here so the idea that
you're generally speaking the flow is
that your basic personality traits
caused by these basic settings of
parameters that have a strong genetic
component to them influence how we adapt
and how we you know what we pick up on
and what habits we develop in any
particular situations uh habits is a
good synonym for characteristic
adaptations um but sometimes there can
actually be feedback so let's say for
example that I'm an introvert but uh for
whatever reason I get into a job that
has a an important component is selling
things right I get into sales somehow so
I'm going to have to develop at least in
that context the ability to act like an
extrovert if I'm going to be successful
in my job and maybe I get good at that
right so I've got a characteristic
adaptation to my particular Niche which
is that at least in this context I'm
good at acting like an
extrovert but this acknowledges that
there's the possibility for that to feed
back and actually make me more sensitive
to incentive reward words in general and
so I may actually find that I'm not just
more extroverted in this particular job
context after five years of doing this
maybe I'm more extroverted in my life as
a whole in all these other contexts um
so that's the one of those feedback
loops and then so you see that there's a
the environment can directly affect the
kind of ways in which we adapt to our
environment obviously but the
environment um but genetics any effect
of genetics on our specific adaptations
must feed through the effects of
genetics on these General mechanis isms
these parameters that underly our
functioning um and so you know if
anybody has any other questions about
that diagram I'm happy
to respond that was a great explanation
and just to um emphasize one point there
and then we'll go to Stephen you said
that the characteristic adaptations in
life outcomes are exhaustive and so um
that really is like we can partition
them into the adaptations or the things
that the agent carries with them the
synapses that have changed or the scars
they bear but basically what is not
their surrounding and the life outcome
is the niche so then there's this stigma
G where the agent is doing Niche
construction so this is from a different
nonactive inference non- Niche
construction framework but finding
resonances and finding uh concordances
here because that's kind of what we talk
about like the learning of agents and
then the way that influences their Niche
and then you had this idea of acting as
if like the example with the person
who's um being forced by their Niche to
implement uh I'm a kind of person who
says hello in this way or things like
that and then that also relates to what
Steph was saying earlier about drama and
about performance so maybe Stephen do
you have a thought on
that yeah I mean the the the thing I
like about what was mentioned here is
how personality traits can be adapted to
context like someone's A salesperson I
thought was a useful example and then
how that obvious starts to then change
your whole broader way of seeing things
and one area I think might be
interesting and I've been there's the
work of Harry Hest who's revisiting this
the work of Roger Barker from the 60s we
did a lot of work on Behavior settings
so he looked at a whole load of children
across the US and he looked at how their
behavior was when they were in a school
or in the cafe or different places he
found the difference in
Behavior between settings for the same
child was bigger than the difference in
Behavior between personalities of
children I the same child was changing
its Behavior radically based on the
settings um and that that work kind of
got lost but Harry heft has sort of been
really pushing that again I I think that
can tie into this is maybe there's
personality
traits I suppose you you know how much
stability there is but could Behavior
settings be kind of like that kind of
more Dynamic version personality traits
and I think active
inflence makes that more possible to
even have that conversation rather than
the more sort of static
psychometric data which is kind of toped
down and kind of you just have to accept
it feels like this is M you can get in
there and play with it a bit more from
different
directions thanks for assuring that
Stephen we'll go Colin and then anyone
else who raises their hand yeah so
that's a really a really good point
Stephen which is that
uh there is there are differences that
people have to specific situations that
are distinct from their broad patterns
of consistency and personality and
that's a long running debate in
personality psychology going back to the
to the late 60s um and the resolution to
it basically is that yes there are these
relatively stable ways in which people
respond to specific situations and
that's what I'm trying to capture with
the idea of characteristic adaptations
but then if you go across a bunch of
character a bunch of situations and you
take the person's average there are also
persistent averages that differ from
person to person and that would
correspond to the trait so you can have
both of these things in the same set of
data um andh will fleen is a personality
psychologist who has really been
instrumental in collecting the data to
show this very basic feature of what are
we measuring when we measure a
personality trait with something like a
questionnaire where we're just asking
somebody for this sort of general
impression of themselves and so what
he's done is used experience sampling
methods where you like you have
somebody's smartphone and it you know
pings them like five times a day and
asks them like how have you been acting
for the last you know half an hour or
for the last hour and then you get them
to rate their behavior on a set of uh
you know on a set of descriptions or
categories what you see is that uh as
you said people have as much or even
more variability within their own
behavior as there is variability in
terms of their average behavior from
person to person and yet nonetheless
those averages are quite stable so if
you do this for one week you can get a
whole you'll get a he calls them density
distributions right you basically just
get a you know and they're usually
fairly normally shaped um and you do
that for one week you get this whole
pattern so sometimes the person's acting
very introverted sometimes they're
acting very extroverted you know at
ranges um but there's there's a peak and
that Peak is very stable if you do it
again in another week so the person goes
through another week of behavior and
again they're varying very l in their
behavior but if you look at their
average level of that particular
Behavior it's quite stable over time and
so and then he's also shown that that
correlates quite highly with the ratings
that we get from these General
personality questionnaires so the
questionnaires really are tapping into
this sort of General average tendency of
specific behavior even though of course
the behavior itself varies widely from
situation to situation and over time
both due to situational affordances and
due to whatever is going on internally
in terms of the goals that the person is
pursuing at that moment awesome let's go
Marco then
Adam thanks it was actually really
interesting I apologize I'm going to add
another interesting thing to connect to
so so so someone mentioned Steph
mentioned the uh the kids in the
classrooms and the context and I think
development might be also very
interesting here because um personality
might be relatively stable across the
lifetime but but I think hopefully we
can agree that personality also enriches
um and in in that process of enrichment
and I would also say
empowerment um there's I think you could
say a shift between the balance of
endogenous and exogenous influence on an
agent's behavioral adaptation or to its
to its niches um and so there's a
there's a change in the scope in which
the personality uh has a relatively
large influence on the way they adapt
and I guess I guess I'm just asking
about thoughts on how you might picture
that kind of process of how personality
might actually in the beginning um
largely concern itself with how to
engage with the world such that it might
internalize that which it normally
co-ops from the environment so normally
offload a lot of stuff to behaviorally
adapt which might explain the the
variation due to environments but then
over time as it does so it internalizes
certain heris certain patterns certain
policies and learn from environments to
kind of enrich its personality and then
extend the scope uh of of influence from
their personality um yeah I don't know
if that makes sense but yeah cool
thought Adam and than anyone
else uh so few thoughts from before and
then um some thoughts on Marco's
thoughts um so the flee and description
of uh personality as a kind of a density
uh distribution um I think and the issue
of um the stability of personality and
the variance of it um with within
individuals across context which is part
of the reason the uh book that was this
chapter was part of was called modeling
persons and situations but uh taking
these ideas together uh we're kind of in
the same territory uh that of these
fundamental questions in the free energy
principle of like what is the
ontological status of a non-equilibrium
study State distribution bounded by a
Markov blanket um what's the granularity
over which we can find this this thing
that we're identifying so it's you're
uh and so um col will be able to speak
more to this but this idea of like there
are ways of describing that uh your
degree of variability across context is
itself something that can be stable and
this could be itself part of your
personality um to uh now kind of loop
back uh to what you were just describing
Marco
um I really like that idea um so it's
like you're you're starting
out in a situation where through this
interaction between you and this context
um that you're entering into in certain
ways based on your own expectations and
the expectations of people in the
environment and and the structures that
are there
built up from this there's a certain
stability and then you Bo you
uh this stability um ends up shaping you
um both just as as a consequence of like
this is the thing for you to predict but
also in the active inferential sense and
as you're saying empowerment this is
what's going to help me get better
purchase I'm reducing my uncertainty
with respect to realizing the value of
uh existing and so this um idea your
personality being kind of um
internalization of structure and maybe
at a certain stage almost like a kind of
amortized inference um in terms
of I got from you
uh yeah I really like that idea a lot
cool Adam
Shannon you're muted ch
thank you um going on this developmental
thread and um the paper that you brought
up this morning Daniel and um Anna's
newpaper on the the first priors when
you're in ruro as a baby I haven't read
it yet but
um the idea that like when you're in a
neonate in a body you're literally
relying on someone
else's interceptive States and
biological states to regulate everything
about your inceptive in biological
States and then you're born and you're
still kind of relying on um that
caregivers inceptive States or their
behavior when they're holding you or
coming to comfort
you um
this I think could relate to what Marco
was saying about how your personality de
develops so first if you have if a
personality is something like a
collection of effective States and
behaviors
and an infant is completely sort of
reliant on the environment and the
social environment to regulate its own
personalities and as you grow through
toddlerhood you slowly are able to
control this yourself like you can
maintain your own body budget a little
bit more um learn how to how to get your
own blanket if you're cold or like self
soothe and then you grow older and maybe
you're taught how to make music and
learning that this is a new way that you
can explore your personality or create
it um
and I don't study development at all so
sorry if this is wondering maybe Sasha
can pick up on it but I I feel like this
can kind of connect if if instead of
looking or not instead of but in
addition to looking at averages but
looking at like a Time series of
personality development over time and
like you could do at any point in time
or at any range of time some sort of um
like what would be the the active
interests model of your life in infancy
in toddlerhood in you know Rowdy teenage
years and as adult and you'll have you
you'll find these like steady
trajectories at the same time that a bit
R Hope some can pick that up let me
connect that to a few other points So
Adam raised this question of what is the
level of the thing or how do we identify
things from empirical data specifically
so that we can use it in active
inference type or free energy principle
type models do we use renormalization
group or principal component analysis or
some type of adjacency Matrix some type
of marov blanket what are those things
that we're actually going to be modeling
and that reminds me a lot of a theory
called ant uh actor Network Theory by
Bruno Lor and then also on the ant
wavelength Colin was mentioning how
there's so much variation Within
individuals but also St stable
differences between and that reminded me
a lot of my graduate school work with
ant colonies where day-to-day the
variation across all the ant colonies
was extreme if it was raining they would
do one thing if it was very dry versus
if it had rained the day before those
were massive determiners of colony
behavior however across days and even
across years there were stable markers
of colony behavior and there were
characteristic ways in which they
responded to to the environment so it is
possible to have a type of measurement
and understanding of a system which my
adviser established through long-term
observation where you can actually model
this development through time as well as
within a population which doesn't erase
individual differences it actually is
the framework by which individual
differences arise and then Shannon is so
beautiful with music being introduce
like a thread of personality and then
that can be used to explore these
regularities Adam then
Stephen hi um what was the paper that
people are mentioning uh about like
first priors I'll post it in this jitsy
and we'll put it in the YouTube chat but
let's continue without worrying about
this paper
okay go on oh
sorry should I go do you want to can I I
just I was just going to put in one
thing maybe I just um
because I like when it mentions here
relatively stable parameters of cyber
cybernetic mechanisms sort of those kind
of Dynamics and I think that links also
to this idea of how that might change
during our life and thinking about our
lifetime and one thing that I'm very
interested in is is when trauma comes
into play PTSD and other types of
situations and you know it's um it can
really shift the state of someone and
poly vagal Theory kind of talks to that
where we've kind of got this sort of
social co-regulation that we have as
humans but we also have our kind of
Primal kind of fight or flight or gut
sort of sort of fear um responses and
how those things are in a way they
another type of like patent Behavior
which becomes incredibly stable too
stable like you can shut down or you
might get into rage but then over the
period of the day or life the challeng
is they may it may be unregulated about
when they appear so someone might sort
of be a certain way and then they flash
into rage you know and then they come
come back into and their personality is
radically different and I think this is
so there they might be interesting to
bring in that that that as a as a kind
of a what happens when that relatively
stable State itself flips you know um so
the and it so your your your mechanism
might not be cognitive but it might be
in that kind of um polyal system yes the
body influencing phase transitions in
personality or behavior Adam and then
Colin and then
Marco we muted
ad thanks um yes I think uh Colin should
probably speak to what was just brought
up in terms of like what actually
happens with people um but in terms of
uh like a high level of abstraction um
so yeah it seems like there's this sense
in which you can think of Personality as
a kind of core screening but it's and a
kind of renormalization and um in terms
of it existing as a phenomenon and it's
a and epistemically it's a kind of core
straining um afforded by this
renormalization um the this kind of
throwing away a variability as you form
these higher level attracting States um
that you can uh ignore them uh with
within the scope of a certain type of
modeling that you're engaging in with
respect to having certain objectives of
trying to predict certain things um
whether you're a personality modeler
trying to predict someone else or trying
to predict yourself or whatever um
the So within this um looking for this
like
optimal level of epistemic grip in terms
of like the granularity of your
description um
this there you could describe these
cybernetic control parameters as being
uh part of the causal process of what's
responsible and then if you take the
system and you perturb it there's going
to be like a range where like the order
parameter changes and you can get these
nonlinear maybe phase shifts where the
um you're now in a different regime and
it may look like a very different kind
of person because the personality
structure as this stable attractor
Network um can then become
destabilized um and so that would be
like a high level in colge probably
speak to like what actually happens with
people cool yeah call and go for it so
you get these phase shifts in Behavior
but they're often due to persistent
sensitivities in the underlying
mechanisms right so let's take um well
so uh PTSD okay um what you have there
essentially is some kind of traumatic
event uh is an intervention that resets
the sensitivity of the threat systems
and so the that corresponds quite well
to the big five dimension that's labeled
as neuroticism which is an old-fashioned
word but in this context basically just
means sensitivity to all different kinds
of negative emotion um and so obviously
that's heightened in PTSD and what that
means fundamentally is that you've gone
through some kind of traumatic event
that led to your your it wasn't just
learning about a specific event right
what it did was that it reset the
sensitivity of your threat system as a
whole so now you are perceiving threats
and reacting with defensive negative
emotion to much more minor situations
than you would have
previously um and of course even in
terms of risk for PTSD we know that
people who are higher in threat
sensitivity to begin with are more
likely to develop PTSD so it's not like
it comes out of nowhere typically but
nonetheless there obvious vious ly this
change um and there was a a recent
really nice meta analysis of Personality
change following uh therapy and
different types of psychotherapy whether
it's pharmaceutical or talk therapy or
cognitive behavioral therapy all of
these lead to changes in personality and
the the trait that changes the most as
you might expect is reductions in
neuroticism right so uh what we're
talking about here is the ability to
shift these underlying parameters that
are not constantly manifest in the same
way so when we say that somebody's high
in trade anxiety for example we don't
mean that they're experiencing anxiety
at every minute of every day at a high
level right we just mean that they're
more likely to be anxious more intensely
in more situations than somebody who is
low in trade anxiety but nonetheless
then if we really want to understand the
Dynamics of the system we need to
understand those phase shifts from like
feelings of safety to feelings of
anxiety at any given moment and I that's
what you're talking about but in order
to understand how that works for a given
agent we also need to understand these
persistent patterns of the sensitivities
that lead them to have these shifts in
different situations and to different
degrees than other
agents very cool thank you Marco then
blue thanks um yeah this is really
interesting so um trying to tie back to
the earlier talk about um the role of a
effect to this aspect of trauma so I
think it's mentioned before by by the
two authors that that um we could uh
validly see these complex systems as
composed of uh different micr
personalities distributed over scale and
levels um and and similarly for affect
in the sense written about by KAS per
has and others so um Adam safron Adam
also mentioned renormalization right so
so I think that ties in also to a lot of
different things like Stig or
equilibration and I think perhaps it's
it's a had a thought or don't want to
share is maybe maybe um the clustering
phenomenon of personalities might be a
natural consequence of something like
renormalization or equilibration if
there already is a certain heterogeneity
if there already is a certain kind of a
symmetry in certain factors certain
basic mechanisms of the CTIC uh systems
shed throughout uh then that naturally
should cluster because then they are
more likely to cooperate if it remains
hetrogeneous and disordered or not
co-organized uh then it's inefficient
but then you have this thing with trauma
which I think would disrupt that process
right because if you go back to the
component you pointed out interpretation
goals and strategy then that's basically
the key things about a trauma right
you're in a certain situation that just
demands an extreme change in your
interpretational beliefs or models your
goals for the particular situation and
the extreme pressure to have the right
strategy to get out of it
and I I think maybe the the the the side
effect right the byproduct of that
momentary extremeness is that it
basically expands it influence and so it
it it becomes hypers sensitive by nature
and so uh the ongoing the always ongoing
process of equilibration of everything
co-regulating um becomes disrupted by
that one participant the traumatic
complex um if that makes sense so inste
of a lot of different not these kind of
equilibrating with each other kind of
polycentric it becomes a monocentric
equilibration if that makes sense it's
AIT rambly lots of very interesting
points thank you blue and then
Adam so just to kind of take the trauma
aspect maybe to the other side of the
spectrum and and just in thinking about
um you know like our own perception of
our self right like so how we hold on to
our own like person person ality versus
is it you know congruent with what
others think of us so I've thinking you
know as how does this really relate to
um meditation right like so in in
meditation there's like the idea of
getting rid of the aita right like so
where like that's the thing that builds
the ego or like the construct of eye so
as we like eliminate this like construct
of eye and also like staying in the
moment right like we're not necessarily
trying to build an accurate predictive
model in in a meditation state so so
when we have this like it's like this
dissolution of of like free energy or or
or what is happening like in in the
meditative State um that that can also
bring about a drastic personality shift
I think as we get get rid of the eye and
learn to be non-reactive as opposed to
like traumatic reaction that's nonlinear
acceleration awesome Adam and then Marco
then Colin and then anyone else who
wants to raise your hand
hi um so I I just try to address a
couple of the threads
um come to meditation uh at the end I
think but the
um it seems
like a lot of the um principles of
personality
uh in terms of their generality uh could
be really interestingly modeled um
actually using things like an colonies
uh like in Daniel's work um and you
might even find interestingly like even
similar mechanisms at play so like in a
recent paper starting to do active
inferential modeling of and Colony uh
Behavior Uh decisions and foraging um
Daniel mentions like you know there's
like the was it the foragers have more
dopamine
so you could see things like um the
functional significance of dopamine
actually as it's way of parameterizing a
cybernetic system as being potentially
similar although potentially switching
across scales where in the individual
ant and maybe even in in the personality
of the colony as a whole and uh there's
would be actually this interesting
interplay between the personalities of
individual ants and the personalities of
colonies and this interplay which might
not be an exactly a one for one might
actually even be a kind of um uh
complimentarity where certain
characteristics being present on um this
broader level this this more
encompassing marov blanket where the
individuals are part of a superorganism
or just the organism um from the
perspective of natural selection because
the colonies that which is selected uh
as Daniel says um but so the person out
of the colony
let's say um would then interface and
interact with the personality of the uh
the individuals of which it's composed
and uh potentially in an in training way
but potentially not um to loop around um
you might even be able to uh at the
level of of colony talk about things
like the aect of tendencies that it's
you know it's what is its what is the
affect the veillance the emotions
experienced by the colonies is a whole
in a given instance what is its
um uh General mood and then what are its
patterns of mood across different
situations it's and you might now we're
kind of going into what we more call
personality territory and you could even
think of things like um to kind of bring
in some of like Marco's idea of the
nature of trauma and this like dynamic
system sense like you could traumatize
The Colony and does it then at some
point like
there you would expect some sort of like
elasticity or um what's the term like
Hyer I don't know not that but it would
be you perturbate and then it it would
have some sort of adapt potential to
come back from the peration because
that's
what we're trying to do is H keep
existing in the way we are and so some
adaptive potential but you push it too
far uh and then you might not get back
this um adaptive attracting structure
you might get stuck in a different
regime
um and you could think of the same
things uh similar
things this could be a way of describing
things that happen within the within uh
individuals like so there's
um you can think of that maybe on
multiple levels of abstraction but stop
for now thanks yep I just switched the
slide to figure two so Colin and then
Marco go for it and maybe we can
introduce the p struct idea or just how
does active inference specifically help
us address some of these questions but
go ahead call in and then Marco Okay
well what I'm my thoughts are about a
couple of the last comments so they're s
more related to the to the previous
slide and then go ahead then it's fine
um so in terms of both this discussion
of what's going on in trauma and what's
going on in meditation I think one of
the interesting things to think about
again is the distinction between the
personality traits and the
characteristic adaptations um because in
uh in both there's the capacity for both
of them to be shifted so uh Marco was
talking about the way in which in a
traumatic event uh you basically
pre-existing goals and interpretations
and strategies are dramatically
invalidated and and that uh you know
then means that the system doesn't know
how to pursue its goals in fact it may
not even know what its goals should be
and obviously that's extremely
disruptive and disregulated and so one
of the challenges in the immediate of
course is to figure out uh what you
should be doing what strategies you
should be using but then there's also
this capacity for that traumatic event
uh to shift the underlying sensitivities
of the system to what is perceived as
disruptive in future right to sensitize
to to things that disrupt um and that is
you know obviously an adapted response
to say like if you're in a in a
dangerous environment you should become
more sensitive to uh to danger and the
traumatic event just basically taught
you that the world was a much more
dangerous place than you thought that's
part of what is uh tragic about it right
because you have this persistent sense
that the world potentially is much is
much more dangerous even than it is or
that you should experience it as being
but then you have the same kinds of
Dynamics going on in um in meditation
where trying to reduce your reactivity
that's like trying to shift some of
these basic parameters of the system so
that you you know react less easily
you're disrupted less easily and then
the kind of non eye idea the recognition
of the the elusory nature of the eye
what that's about is basically not being
overly attached to your uh model of
yourself right because the the model is
a model it's not yourself so if you are
overly attached to your model then you
have you're overly attached to your
conscious understanding of what your
goals and your strategies are and what
you're like and meditation is basically
trying to get you to recognize that
those ideas that you have a they're just
a they're just your model they're not
actually the way that you are and B
they're contingent on your situation and
so you should be willing to let them go
as your situation changes and as things
evolve and so it's essentially creating
both a pattern of Greater flexibility in
the capacity to adapt uh but then also
the attempt to uh downregulate the
negative reaction to disruption right
because if you have more confidence in
your ability to adapt then you should uh
be less defensively reactive to
disruptions because you can be confident
that you'll simply adapt to whatever the
the new situation is thanks Marco
yeah thanks um yeah just just
piggybacking on that because that was
really nice um so so so my thoughts on
meditation and very good and important
question I think um so so going back to
the image of having all these different
distributed micr personalities or sub
personalities I think meditation can be
seen as allowing them to manifest and
arise as it often is called and manifest
their the Expressions which are always
going on to also reach as a were the
global workspace or Consciousness or the
uh conscious attention and so what
you're doing then effectively is
broadening the collective of sub agents
or subpersonalities or subsystems such
that that equilibrative process improves
because then you have a bigger scope a
bigger domain of possible inputs to an
ongoing process of inference um and
importantly this is then of course
without need for explicit modeling
you're don't need to explicitly label a
certain um rationally or verbally
explicated belief right it's an exercise
in in in the in the deepest sense of it
uh importantly it's it's it's
effectively a reflexive Niche
construction because meditation is
systematically to basically dis
attenuate to yeah to attenuate external
inputs you sit in a very neutral
position you you're in a calm
environment external input is minimized
and so all the inputs well it augments
the inputs that is endogenous coming
from within which of course um is then
going to translate or transfer to normal
waking States because those are all the
endogenous or it concerns all the
possible indulgist influences on your
ongoing
cybernetics and so it's it's it's a
reflective shift right and yeah I don't
know what I was going to say uh yeah so
it's basically just a sertic game so
from what I have seen my limit
experience with meditation and reading
upon it it's it's all systematic
cybernetic games it puts you in a
situation that that forces you to train
the process that underly sonetics
concerning the purely reflexive which is
of course beautiful because there's
almost no opportunity for that it's an
extremely exclusive state of being that
exclusively uh forces you to attend to
these indous processes it's kind of the
sbics of the sbics if that makes sense
great points there it's why so much
meditation begins with thankfulness and
just to give actually one behavioral
example um let's think about the example
of a circus elephant where when it's
young it has a heavy chain and it can't
break away and then when it's older a
simple thin rope can keep it connected
so at a first pass one might say um well
why doesn't it just break away why
doesn't it engage in a policy of
breaking away and the habits the E the
priors over the policy the field of
affordances may not even include that as
an option so if certain types of actions
are down regulated so to speak by 100x
before any evidence comes in then it's
going to be interpreted within a prior
that downregulates or basically
downweights the relevance or the
likelihood of certain types of actions
happening but also there's this element
of the preferences where it may through
whatever mechanism it's not an exact
metaphor here the system kind of like a
Stockholm syndrome situation the system
can actually uh uh internalize a
preference for certain States that may
or may not be consciously available
during regular States Of Consciousness
that lead into the implicit processing
of everything within a framework that
results in Behavior that's not aligned
with something else which could be
external Niche pressure or peer pressure
or it could be disconcordant with one's
own narrative thems and then meditation
is interesting to think about as far as
isolating these different types of
parameters in the model and different
kinds of meditation lots of different
ways to do it Adam
hi
um hard to follow up on all that the
um some the way the threads came
together for me uh
was it seems like across varieties of
meditation
and why would you do such a thing um and
ultimately like to bring back maros
point about empowerment um it's you want
to be more capable in some way having a
better grip on existence and a
particular kind of way uh you want to be
you have more you want to have um more
degrees of freedom uh with respect to
the way you're engaging with the world
and there's a sense in which you can
think of different types of meditation
as either as allowing you to uh navigate
through
cybernetically uh free free energy
Landscapes which can uh and and and also
adjust the nature of these Landscapes
such that they are navigable so uh you
can think of something like and to bring
back in like something like trauma or
something like uh the elephant getting
stuck you can think of this as like a a
getting stuck at a local Optimum um of
of a potentially Jagged free energy
landscape and so if you can uh let's say
reduce the uh some emotional uh
regulation capacity the ability to
defuse from an experience and keep the
gain on positive feedback loop cycles of
thought and emotion from getting as high
as they might uh you might be able to
make the free energy landscape less
Jagged the differen is from point to
point it's going to be uh you're not g
to have these wild swings and so this
might give you greater latitude with
respect to pursuing more complex uh
policies and actually I hope at some
point we start to discuss some of
colins's work on well-being because I
think it it docks uh there's a lot to be
said there um but uh one thing uh on
this one podcast con was mentioning like
you can think of one of the benefits of
mindfulness uh which is like in pursuing
any kind of complex goal um there's
going to be a sort of trading off you're
going to have to do against different
things on on road there and so if you
can like temporarily uh let some of your
characteristic adaptations slide um let
some of your uh policies like not be as
important if they're if they're not
being you think they ought to be
realized but they're not within some
sort of like hierarchical hierarchical
policy selection well then you can
pursue uh you can hit targets you wouldn
otherwise you can you're a mountain car
you can get to the top of the mountain
um and the mountain car problem um
so yeah nice cool Colin and then anyone
else I just wanted to to say to point
out that that's that's the essence of
non-attachment right you're not attached
to particular policies and that means
that you don't get hung up on a subg
goal when you should be shifting
policies because what you are trying to
pursue is some larger goal there's sort
of you know there's The Stereotype of uh
meditation at least you know Zen
meditation for example Buddhist
meditation that you're eliminating your
goals right you have no desires but
that's not that is a that's a caricature
right because it's not that you have no
goals it's just that you're not attached
to particular low-level goals you might
be uh you know you probably remain
attached to if you're a good Buddhist
for example to eliminating suffering for
all beings and so it's not like you're
not go directed and you know you
probably maintain maintain life by
eating and things like this it's just
that you're not attached to the
particular policies that might be using
uh to achieve these higher level goals
because goals are are just nested I mean
there's a way in which there's a goal
but then the policy is also just a goal
it's just there're nested goals all the
way down to the terminals which are
specific motor operations or specific
cognitive operations and so
non-attachment is basically becoming
more flexible in which subg goals you
are willing to consider and to
use very nice blue
so I wonder if it's like it's more that
it's not attachment to the policy but
that actually is the policy and it's not
attachment to the specific generative or
predictive model I wonder if that's like
because the policy is then the policy of
non-attachment to the model or or
Ultimate model
flexibility right you could call it a
metap policy metap policy right and and
so um and like secondly I wonder about
uh you know the idea of staying in the
in the present moment is this like some
kind of free energy equilibrium like in
and not necessarily minimization but
like if we take the generative model and
the predictive model if we take like the
value to zero are we like is meditation
like staying in the present moment just
like this ultimate state of of
equilibrium in in free energy like
infodynamics well interesting point
about the hyper prior the basian hyper
prior and also that's why a lot of
meditation processes involve rhythmic or
the cessation of other inputs because it
allows the interception potentially to
proceed in a different way isolation
tanks or uh other Altered States Of
Consciousness so let's do keeping
comment short because we only a few
minutes left Adam and then
Marco in terms of the there's this one
paper actually that just came out
recently about a model of meditation
with respect to um the temporal depth
and counterfactual richness of uh your
generative modeling that just came out
I'll try to find that and send that but
I think that would speak to this idea of
staying in the present moment also this
idea of um staying in the present moment
um also makes me think of this uh Mark
was like kind of intimating that you can
think of meditation as a kind of uh like
game task or almost like a kind of like
uh maybe maybe play even uh but it's
this
building
capacity um that
is building
capacity okay we'll come back Marco for
okay uh so so a building of capacity
through relaxing some of your priors and
so letting um you to be uh informed by
uh policies with respect to mental acts
that you might not normally deploy and
you might not normally notice um what is
entailed when you deploy certain types
of mental act so things might come to
mind uh that wouldn't normally uh that
would place you now in into a different
state of uh affective inference and so I
think uh if we wanted to do uh modeling
of this of something like meditation uh
we would want to use this sort of
imaginative policy selection described
by something like sophisticated um
effect of inference and that would begin
to get us there um the exact way and one
more thought before we move on is um one
more thing I I was actually wondering
with respect to meditation I've talked
about this some with Colin is uh above
the traits in the personality hierarchy
you have these metat traits of stability
and
plasticity and um
stability uh is this shared variance
over and uh Colin actually named these
um it's the shared variance over
neuroticism inverse neuroticism
agreeableness and conscientiousness and
plasticity is the shared variance over
extroversion and openness intellect and
interestingly the stability seems to be
basically the inverse of the general
Psychopathology Factor P um by and large
um but I I think thinking of mindfulness
and meditation with resp back to um
building capacities for both stability
and plasticity which um helping to U um
basically place this so you can think of
stability as your ability to follow
through on and protect your policies or
characteristic adaptations and then
plasticity would be your tendency to
form new characteristic adaptations so
like whether um so let's say you do
encounter trauma um plasticity might be
what makes the difference so stability
would be how much it might make sense to
the degree to which you're actually
traumatized like you're very stable
something might you know bounce right
off you you're you're not traumatized
but let's say you don't have a lot of
plasticity and that instability is
compromised plasticity is the thing that
would let you update and uh create new
strategies uh for being in the world and
so they're kind of the state of dynamic
tension in that they can like pull at
each other
um but they're both ultimately
synergistic in that like you're not
going to be particularly plastic unless
you have this Foundation of stability
and you're not going to be able to
maintain your stability long unless
you're metastable and so um part of with
meditation mindfulness I'm wondering if
one way of thinking of it is it's part
of what's actually really letting you
kind of like ride this Optimum of
balance stability and plasticity and
that could be one way of thinking about
part of what um people get from it cool
Marco then
Colin yeah that's amazing that's it's a
perfect setup yeah um I I I also fully
agree with this theme of complimentarity
right so stability and plasticity sounds
really it resonates with picity sorry
openness and focus which is a big
complimentary Uhl yeah big po polarity
in meditation practices right so if open
meditation just feel everything let it
all come in ETC Focus meditation you
know focus on one point one
Mantra um and that's has a bigger
connection to the the more well-known
complimentarity or polarity of
exploration exploitation right but it's
not about the polarities per se it's
it's always about the balancing them Ma
and for example Sussex had also a nice
paper on that it's not about perfect
thetical representations you can have
some errors it's about how you balance
everything off and so again we go back
to the idea notion that that meditation
can be games where you effectively
practice and balancing that on cuz that
balance is not something you can
explicitly verbalize it's intrinsically
preverbal because you can verbalize
maybe the particular strategies or
beliefs for Ability or for picity but to
balance them off is more effective it's
more flexible or fluid and so the the
another interesting maybe Duality that
that you can think of is also
equilibriums and games or contexts right
so in Game Theory you have an
equilibrium for a particular game or
setting and so what you said earlier
about equilibrium and staying in the
moment uh regarding meditation I think
it's a very nice idea what what Adam
already said is that um by being in that
particular game which is that meditative
practice um you will naturally by free
energy minimization go to a particular
kind of equilibrium but that NE
necessitates change some updates and
those updates might actually mean that
your equilibrium seeking Behavior or
your attractors will be different in the
other context so the underlying
assumption is that these particular
changes in equilibriums or priors or
attractors um are transferable so um
yeah does that make sense as for your
question on meditation presence in the
presence yeah cool thoughts
Colin I was just going to say a little
bit more about stability and plasticity
um I think that those can be seen as the
two fundamental uh needs of any
cybernetic or active inference system
that exists in a complex or changing or
unpredictable environment right so
stability is in some sense just the the
most fundamental requirement because the
system must be able to pursue its goals
effectively in order to be a cybernetic
system right if it's an organism that's
what it must have in order to persist
and even an artificial system in order
to persist as the system that it is it
must be moving effectively toward it its
goals um but then if you have any degree
of unpredictability in the environment
you can't just be satisfied with the
same set of policies that you have at
any given time you're going to have to
be able to update your policies generate
new policies and so then immediately in
order to remain stable over time in a
changing environment you also have to be
somewhat adaptive or plastic and and so
you have these uh inherent Necessities
for the capacity to maintain a stable
order of goal directed functioning and
then the capacity to generate uh
new components of the model right new
policies or even new goals or new
interpretations of the of the situation
that you're in and then those so those
are complimentary but they can also they
are also in Dynamic tension as Adam
mentioned because if you're massively
exploratory it can be difficult to
remain stable because you have so much
new uh you know information coming in um
similarly if you are well I mean we've
essentially already covered what the the
danger of being too inflexible and too
unexplored as things change over time
then you become unadapted to your
situation so stability and plasticity
aren't opposite to each other right
stabil the opposite of stability is
instability the opposite of plasticity
is rigidity you can be uh stable and
plastic or stable and rigid you can be
unstable and plastic and unstable and
rigid cool Adam go ahead
hi
um it seems like at some point it could
be good to discuss connections of um
narrative perspectives on personality
because this idea of um narrative as
active inference and the work trying to
be done there I think there could be
like a rich interchange because in some
ways you can think of know selves as
centers of narrative gravity and you can
think of person as um styles and modes
of narration and themes and motifs as
you are this semi-reliable narr narrator
telling your story and making and
enacting it and making it so to degrees
um and this being a source of to the
degree you have stability and plasticity
um this would be one source of it the
ability of narratives to provide cross
situational intertemporal common context
and but also because of their richness
to create this um Rich this kind of
their combinatorics and Rich
representative capacity also being a
source of plasticity and so um narrative
being a source of balance Dynamic
balancing this Dynamic tension although
the narrative itself can also not be a
source of balance but imbalance if the
style of naration becomes problematic so
that kind of mindfulness enters in there
again where um it might like your usual
styles of narrative narrative I ation
you might let that go a bit you go um
this is this is the way in which you go
naive Bays on your expectations um yep
the stories provide the polls and the
archetypes and then you can say okay
it's like Goldilocks but for the
internet of things or something like
that and that gives you a vocabulary to
communicate and design you might need a
very different story in a very different
context and kind of bring it back to
trauma that might be all the difference
between whether you get stuck or you
experience post-traumatic growth yeah
cool interesting and just um one closing
uh slide that I want to put up while
people prepare their thoughts this is a
question just from uh audience member
they wrote I have a question about what
happens when blankets intersect blankets
of blankets and so let's think about
this in this kind of blankets of
physiologically relevant States
informationally relevant what what um
think about what we're talking about
here and at which nodes that would
happen and then there's a link to a talk
by Carl friston and a question about how
nodes intersect and just while people
are thinking about this or their last
thoughts on the paper uh one note is
about the scientist and the personality
scientist as an informational forager as
an active inference agent themselves and
so our quest to reduce uncertainty about
personality it shouldn't be about the
optimal descriptor it should lead to a
question of ourselves which is what is
the optimal perturbation that we can
design that will reduce our uncertainty
the most about this individual's
personality
and so that takes into account
population level Dynamics as a prior but
personalized and um kind of dynamic
testing so imagine having a baseline
prior across knowledge architectures
that people had and then having a
dynamically updating online course that
was optimally informative from both
sides of the interface it was optimally
informative for what kind of learner the
person was and they were reducing their
uncertainty optimally about the topic at
hand and so that was like a
co-evolutionary process
amidst a prior that was population level
but personalized in the individual
trajectory so it's a really interesting
framework in col and Adam thanks a lot
for coming on the stream was like really
helpful and we're excited that you'll
come back for next week so in these last
couple minutes anyone can raise your
hand give a last thought what would be
something that we would want to say to
this slide about how nodes intersecting
stories intersecting individuals
intersecting how does that come into
play and or what should we be thinking
about for 13.2 that would be good to
cover Shannon and then anyone else who
raises their
hand I guess I have a thought about um
the question on this slide um so is um
one node that's a sent state in one
blanket the internal state of another
blanket like that's totally the case
because you basically choose a
perspective and whichever you know
blanket sort of internal State you want
to describe or whichever thing that
you're calling the agent separate from
its environment then that's the internal
state that you're going to describe and
if you're looking at like if this blue
node is a neuron and you want to
actually know about this pink node this
other neuron's internal State then
that's going to be your internal State
and these other guys are going to be the
sent State the blanket around it and
that's going to be the statistical
boundary that you're using to explain
the behavior of that neuron and then you
can Aggregate and this collection of
neurons will all be an internal State
for the next collection of neurons so
the answer is in the question that's
exactly right perfect answer showing
that the answer is in the question is
the answer
Adam uh in terms of uh loop around to a
previous thought in terms of nested uh
blankets um and where these different
blankets might have different
characteristics in their interaction
um for personality uh there's some
interesting work um colum might disagree
on tight and loose cultures where you
can think of like the personality of the
culture you're within and this tightness
and looseness seems to correspond to
this stability plasticity Dynamic
tension this fundamental cybernetic
parameters showing up on the group level
and you in theory can get this kind of
complimentarity there where a tight
culture might create more tight um
individuals with respect to the degree
to which you they let their their Pol
whether they have a metap policy of
letting their policy slide more um in
different context but uh or instead of
it being this sort of entrainment
relation it could be a complimentary
relation where the stability on the
level of the group this broader um uhou
attractor affords the fine grain the
subsystems to actually have more
latitude and vice versa um and I I
imagine you might probably see similar
things play out like with ant colonies
um interesting point about multi-level
systems and how they're associated with
relative constraints in the last two
three minutes let's think of a last you
know if anyone who wants to raise their
hand give a word or a sentence or few
what is something that you took away or
was exciting today and what was
something that we could continue talking
about in 13.2 and pick up where we left
off Marco and then just anyone else who
raises their
hand yeah I just wanted to thank
everyone this was like really amazing
this my first this this kind of stream
seminar uh in ages so thank you is
innovating and I think in general what
to be taken away I think is is uh
excitement because it's kind ofing how
many different domains and topics and
questions have been successfully
synthesized in this big discussion and I
think that's a testament to the power of
these kinds of Frameworks of invasion or
Active inflence frean Energy C etics
when it comes to understanding us people
us persons personalities um as
individuals as as collectives so thank
you again for exciting me thank you well
said and the group performance is uh
only realized it's only in acted even
digitally when the people show up and
it's only relevant when there's the
regime of attention and so there's so
much you know fun and it's great to have
you um multiple of you on your first
time here that's always appreciated so
any other thoughts in the last minute
otherwise in the calendar invite is a
feedback form so if you're just wanting
to think a little bit more if you're
live participant you want to think a
little more about what we could cover
next week just put it in that feedback
form and then anyone who's watching it
just leave a comment for something that
we could address even if it's after 13.2
maybe we can swoop back and return to
some previous comments but this was a
super fun discussion and a big thanks to
all the participants so really good
times everyone and thanks a
lot so see you next week